good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show live from my
hometown of wigan i've returned to my
roots for a week of special coverage
looking at the cost of living crisis and
the impact on the people who are living
here over the course of the week we'll
travel around the town hearing people's
stories from my first school to wigan
mosque to the infamous uncle joe's
menthols factory and the wigan warriors
rugby club to name just a few today
we're here in beech hill where i grew up
to spend the morning with the sheikah
family whose finances are so stretched
they're lighting candles when their page
you go meter runs out we'll hear from
some of their neighbors and friends as
well about how their cost of living
crisis has affected them we'll also ask
the government what they're doing to
help the home office minister rachel
mcclain will join us and we'll talk to
the former boss of sainsbury's who's
warning that the golden era of cheap
food is ending big day two in northern
ireland as the prime minister heads
there with the government preparing to
publish legislation to override the
protocol we're joined by ireland's
minister of european affairs later in
the programme it's monday the 16th of
may
cost of living crisis we're here in
wigan to find out how people are
affected as one report suggests the
prime minister thinks issues like the
northern ireland protocol are
restricting his ability to deal with the
cost of living
and we're just down the road from k at a
community hub where they're taking the
cost of living crisis into their own
hands
out of pocket we'll be talking about
that in more detail as well as we move
into the home of shiki
when you know you've done 63 64 65 hours
but then a shift comes up for the likes
of a six hour shift and you think
physically can i and i think but it's
that extra little bit of money
i'm feeling like angelina jolie being
the ambassador for the un i am going to
sort these two out
we'll meet the wiganer turned real
housewife of cheshire tanya bardsley to
discuss life as a northern businesswoman
[Music]
and the songs and celebrities who will
never give up on wigan will take you
through my hometown's historic music
scene
also on the programme for you this
morning live from mickey's kitchen
boris johnson heads to belfast for
crisis talks on the storm and deadlock
as the government prepares to publish
legislation to override the brexit
protocol
i'm in hakeev where ukrainians say they
have won the battle for this city
and sweden and finland move closer to
joining nato
fueled by a diet of hate new details on
the deadly supermarket shooting in
buffalo city with the suspect on suicide
watch
a standing ovation for the queen as she
attends the first major event
celebrating her platinum jubilee
[Music]
good morning everybody live from wigan
we are going to be here throughout the
week the uk is in the grip
of an ever worsening cost of living
crisis inflation is soaring and forecast
to rise again this week putting
household finances under severe strain
this week i'm in wigan to find out how
people are coping in this northwest town
my hometown i'm here with shiki and her
family mika who mickey i should say
forgive me who works as a child minder
and her children zara and kanechi who
are struggling with their bills when
their pay as you go mita runs out mickey
lights candles and school meals she says
are a luxury let's take you through our
week and uh where we are going today
we're in beach hill where i grew up on
the council estate here and tomorrow
we'll be heading a short way over to
beach hill community primary school my
first school
where we'll be joining their breakfast
club and hearing from children parents
and teachers plus the mayor of greater
manchester andy burnham then on
wednesday morning we'll be at the brick
which is a local food hub providing for
those who are struggling most with their
rising food prices and then on thursday
morning we'll be in a family-run bakery
taking a look at how local businesses
are coping
today we are as i said in beech hill
where i grew up these pictures hopefully
we can see them from the drone where
we're showing the council estate i know
it's so well i've taken a trip down
memory lane as well quite literally to
revisit the places that shaped my
upbringing in wigan some of which is
struggling now more than ever before
we're on the road all this week we are
in my hometown of wigan to find out the
cost of living crisis and the impact
that it's having on the good people of
this northwest town where these houses
are
this used to be a pub called the beech
tree my mom used to work there behind
the bar to raise a few quid when dad
lost his job for a while and my sister
and i
had to get free school meals um inzy's
going to be with me all week we're going
to the school aren't we beach hill
primary school we are welcome home
primary school um still struggling in
terms of free school meals a lot of
children there 40 of them currently on
free school meals and wigan as a whole
more free school meals here now for
children than five years ago down to the
cost of living crisis
that used to be my old house the first
house i lived in uh that and i lived
there until i was about 15. memories of
this street well uh down the middle of
the road here we used to um
play hopscotch and then see where the
curbs are either side we used to play
kirby so you used to throw the ball and
see if you could hit the ball and send
it back again and then when i was 15 16
just about to do my o levels we moved
just around the corner to beach grove
this is the asda i used to work at when
i was 16 studying for my a levels
i was working on the meat counter here
three days a week three evenings
also running away in harriet
this is where wigan warriors play wigan
athletic who beat manchester city to win
the fa cup final in 2013 at wembley they
also play here but what wonders given
the cost of living crisis and the impact
that it's having on the people of wigan
how much longer will they be able to
afford a ticket to go here
cool this is a walk down memory lane and
see this is this school actually has
been rebuilt since i was who taught me
strong values and be twelve times tables
six twelve
seventy-two well done
quite a few celebrities from wigan as
well you know yeah rick astley yeah he
would never give we're gonna give up
never
richard ashcroft as well from the verve
yep he used to live around the corner
from where i lived at another house in
wigan and kajugu is that right yeah
chris hamill the mall was an anagram of
hamel is he too
shy
we're here all week try the
well as i said i'm thrilled and honored
to be in mickey's kitchen hi thank you
so much for hosting us we really
appreciate it we're obviously talking
about cost of living you're our first
guest we're thrilled to have you um talk
to us about the cost of living crisis
and sort of impact that it has on you
um it's it's been quite um challenging
at the moment i think
with everything going up and then
obviously your salary stays the same the
bills have gone out petrol has gone up
food's gone up so we we're at a point
now where we're just using the local
community grocers we're going shopping
first on the clearance house as opposed
to what we'd normally go for quality so
at the moment is more cost more than
quality yeah so yeah
your bills have gone up to like 50
pounds uh a week 200 pounds yes so
they've got they've literally increased
by 80 pounds
a month and that's a lot i mean
with two children and as well with a lot
of other works that we're doing in the
community that's impacting as well now i
know you've probably seen the prime
minister quite a few uh news conferences
during the pandemic and the like and
he's been asking local people first of
all before he speaks to the journalists
about what they think so we thought we
would do that as well this morning and
that's okay i wondered if you could
indulge us with a question to the
minister is that okay well joining us is
rachel mclean she's minister for
safeguarding and and she is basically a
home office minister um and if you look
just down that lens you can ask her a
question
right so my question to you minister is
my energy bills have risen by 80 pounds
a month
and
where used to be 120 pounds is now
200 pounds if not more
um if you include the petrol and things
so i'm just wanting to ask
what are you going to be doing to help
people like me families like me minister
yeah hello it's lovely to speak to you
and we we understand and we know the
impact that rising energy bills and
bills and costs of food are having on
families like yours all over the country
so we very much do need to make sure
that the support is going to those
families the support packages that we've
already put in place
and we've already put taken action to
help people with energy bills and
there's more help coming
and i think the other point that i think
is really important that families can
i can
take account of is that we have put
money into those local communities who
often know
better than we do in central government
where the need is so
local authorities local areas have got a
household support fund that is available
for families who've got individual
circumstances they might be struggling
and i would definitely recommend any
family who is feeling the pinch at this
time to approach their their local
authority and see what help is on offer
do you want to answer your follow-ups um
yeah with what you've just mentioned now
with helpful families that's available
with um within the local council
i also happen to work with with families
from
communities experiencing um inequalities
and my question is
if those services are available we are
finding as an organization
that
are
the people we work alongside are not
able to access those
the support that's available because of
the certain boundaries if there's a
requirement of a certain paperwork or if
there's um
forms that needs to be online and they
don't have access to that it's become a
lot more complicated and therefore
people are not um accessing that so my
question is what are you putting in
place for those people that it's so easy
to access as opposed to being so
complicated good question minister i
think that's a it's a really good point
and we do recognize that not everybody
has access to the internet and of course
we want to get those funds uh targeted
to where they really need to go as
quickly as possible without excessive
paperwork i mean there has to be some
basic paperwork of course you're talking
about public money and obviously the
government would be criticized if we
didn't take those proportionate steps i
mean i would recommend in your
individual case speak to your local mp i
have this dialogue with my local
organizations often and we are often
able to sign posts and unblock specific
issues that you're having
okay thanks very much indeed thanks a
lot a minister i wonder if i could
follow up on that actually lisa nandy's
the local mp and we will be chatting to
her here in wigan during the course of
the week some of your colleagues think
we should have a government minister for
the cost of living given that inflation
is likely to hit something like 10 at
least 10 percent which will by summit
this year do you think that that is a
good idea
so i've not heard that specific request
but what i would say of course that's
the chancellor's job and it's the job of
the whole cabinet and the whole
government and every minister is looking
at particular costs that are impacting
on the areas that they are controlling
and looking to see where savings can be
made and where reductions can be made
because the cost of living is about
energy bills but it's also about all
those other things that you've mentioned
so i think what we need to focus on now
is over the long term we have got these
short-term pressures on us that we're
all aware of and that your families in
wigan are seeing but over the long term
we need to have a plan to grow the
economy and make sure that people are
able to protect themselves better
whether that is by taking on more hours
or moving to a better paid job and these
are these are long-term actions but
that's what we're focused on as a
government
you say uh taking on more hours i mean
some people that i've been chatting to
minister over the last i've moved
outside actually because obviously they
need to get ready and get the kids ready
for school you know some people are
working three jobs
they're working um every hour that god
sends them so and they're still going to
food banks um to get to get food because
they can't afford to feed their kids you
know so it's not as straightforward as
that is it
no and of course it's not and
i'm not suggesting that for one moment
but we have often heard in the past when
people are facing problems with their
budgets that one of the obstacles and it
may not be for everybody one of the
obstacles is about being able to take on
more hours or even move to a better paid
job and of course
it's an individual situation depending
on on that particular family situation
but that's why the job centers exist
that's why the work coaches exist that's
why we put the support into those job
centres to work with individuals on
their own individual situation so it may
be right for some people they may be
able to access additional hours but of
course it's it's not going to work for
people who are already uh working in
three jobs and that's why we need to
have the other measures in place such as
the um
all the help that we're putting into the
schools uh the the help with the the the
um local
authorities help and support that i've
already mentioned and these are where
we're going to target the help where
it's most needed
i'm reading in my telegraph this morning
that uh
your boss the prime minister is heading
to northern ireland today and he is
blaming the northern ireland protocol on
the cost of living crisis hi so
so if you read what the prime minister
set out in in that article which i think
is a very
balanced piece
he's making it clear that he needs to go
to northern ireland because we need to
have a functioning executive and that is
how with that strong local leadership
the parties can come together
and tackle the cost of living crisis but
of course the situation is urgent
that's why the prime minister is going
to northern ireland to get round the
table with all those parties to find a
way through this
but explain to me how the northern
ireland protocol is damaging the cost of
living
because what's the situation with the
northern ireland protocol is putting
additional costs and paperwork on
businesses
it's affecting the supply of various
products and of course that has a
knock-on impact on the cost of living
and all of the parties in the recent
elections have called for changes to be
made for the protocol everyone
acknowledges that it's not working so
that's why it is really important that
we see hopefully we see some movement
from the eu but the prime minister has
been clear that nothing is off the table
the situation needs to be resolved for
the benefit of the peace and security of
the people of northern ireland
i thought it was an oven-ready deal
theresa may we didn't like her deal so
we got a new prime minister boris
johnson told us it was an oven ready
deal and it's an international treaty
i think you're talking about two
different things there we have a trade
and cooperation agreement with our
european partners that was agreed after
the northern ireland protocol was signed
and inherently built into the protocol
is a consent mechanism and requirements
for all parties to work in good faith to
protect those overriding important
principles of the belfast good friday
agreement now clearly there are issues
with how the protocol is working don't
forget it was also signed before covid
it was signed before a war in ukraine
it is incumbent on all parties to come
together now and and work in good faith
to resolve these practical issues and i
think you know if you look at the
dialogue we've had with the eu we've
been working really hard to put forward
sensible and proportionate proposals to
our eu partners
and we do need to see movement from them
on a number of areas i'll just point to
one one particular issue which is we've
we've made proposals and we've set up
a
an i.t system to ease trade flows and
unfortunately the eu haven't even
implemented that they've not even
started to use it so we've taken a lot
of steps on our side and we really do
want to see that movement now from our
european friends
just to clarify the prime minister is
blaming the situation in ukraine for the
border down the irish sea
no that's not what i said at all i
pointed to a range of factors that have
taken place before
since the protocol was signed and since
the trade and corporation agreement was
negotiated all of which have a bearing
and all parties that are part of this
have a responsibility to the peace and
security of northern ireland
uh but i suppose the
european government would say we looked
at this we realized it was a bit
complicated as far as the paperwork is
concerned and they say that they've
scrapped something like 80 percent of
the paperwork that was previously
necessary as part of the northern
ireland uh protocol so um who's right is
it british government right or is the
european union right and if we do um
decide that we're going to scrap parts
of the northern ireland protocol are you
content that it would be within the law
and you would vote for it
so i think on your first point of course
there are always going to be measures
that have to be negotiated and i think
that's the whole that's the point of a
negotiation with our european partners
this has been going on at pace with
officials with our with our
interlocutors
on the european side and as far as the
subsequent actions that are going to be
taken
a lot of it is speculation but of course
the uk is a country that always lives up
to its international legal obligations
and we will continue to do
that okay just before i let you go
minister i know that you're very busy
this morning we appreciate you taking
the time and i know that mickey
appreciates you answering her questions
um i can see that there's some
suggestions that uh civil servant
numbers should be uh cut in and around a
white hole some 200 miles south of where
we are now perhaps something like 20 in
the home office will the home office
still uh work effectively with a 20
cutting staff
i think it's always right to look at
where taxpayers money is being spent
including on the civil service and i
know from my time in government that we
have added more people rightly so to
help us get through not only the kovid
pandemic but also those brexit
negotiations it's always right to keep
those numbers under review what we're
seeing um in a number of government
departments is actually moving them out
of london so they are closer to the
communities such as wicked and i think
that's a really positive step
okay it's good to talk to you minister
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thanks a lot inside the kitchen uh again
now it'll be breakfast time in just a
second or two it's nippy outside let me
tell you over here in wigan uh we're
gonna actually has been uh earmarked as
one of the times eligible for the
government's 4.8 billion pound leveling
up fund so how does it compare to the
rest of the uk i can hear you asking
this morning we did some digging to get
a statistical snapshot of the town
here's what we found the average annual
salary in wigan is 25
541 pounds just below the uk average but
above the average salary for the
northwest the average house price in
wigan is 157 500 compared to 285 000 in
england while house costs
an average of around five times the
annual salary in wiccan compared to
around nine times the annual salary
across the country
bansi counts at bantee band d i'll say
that again council taxing wigan is 1
678 pounds over 200 pounds cheaper than
the average for england in wigan the
unemployment rate is 4.4 percent
compared to the average of 4.3 the
average
life expectancy for both men and women
in wigan is lower than the average in
england
30.6 of the working age population are
educated to nvq level 4 or higher that
compares to 43 percent of the uk working
age population while 9.3 percent have no
formal qualifications compared to 6.6
of the uk working age population
twenty nine point three percent of
children are classified as being in
poverty just below the average for
england
well let's talk now to ryan connor and
joe mitchenson two twenty eight-year-old
wiganers working on a local video
production business called foxy media
house hello to you both
hi
oh where are they are they here with me
oh okay i'm not sure where they are but
we'll find out in the meantime let's
talk to our lovely host
hi how are the kids doing are they very
well shall we wander around if we could
just move this way and have a chat with
the kids introduce me to them
so these are my facebook you sit down
i'll stand up
oh thank you that's very kind aren't you
awesome
sorry this is my daughter's hour and
this is my son kenneth yeah okay now
tell me how old you are i'm thirty
thirteen and you're eleven which girl do
you go say
john fisher oh john fisher was a posh
school when i was in wigan
tell me what school's like
esquires yeah
i was told you were very talkative
maybe not so much mom what about you
young man it is fun it's fun yeah which
is your favorite subject science science
are you particularly good at science can
you move that out your way yeah which
particular science are you good at
just practicals and things we do yeah um
tell me mom um
what's it like trying to bring up two
kids with the challenges that you're
facing um i think
especially with with everything just
going up like i said before it's really
difficult
you've got school meals which obviously
they've reduced the quality of what they
have as a game you can guess is because
of the prices so it's again going for
price as opposed to quality
um the difficult thing
i don't know
you don't have a favorite food it's not
like fish and chips or anything
it's always like this one trust me don't
worry about it what do you find that is
you tend to be able to cook
um
i think we just turn to make out of mean
with whatever it is that we can get from
um from the community grocery that we
use and
i think the big thing as well is because
our meals are so culturally diverse
we can't just use things like tins where
it's probably easier maybe even cheaper
yeah so you find that it's whatever we
find on the shelf in terms of fresh food
fresh vegetables and obviously meats
it's quite expensive at the moment as
well so we just try and make out a meal
from whatever it is that we can have and
just one of those that they like their
meals
they're good are they fantastic and pet
lunches as well mom would you manage
with that um no actually we pay for
school meals do you so yeah they prefer
school meals and if not sometimes they
make their own yeah so
what time is school
um it's quite tonight oh okay so i'm
gonna have to let you go in a minute
yeah
it's been weird isn't it with all these
camera people all around you
i don't know
morning
it's running up and down isn't it
fantastic i'm loving your hair as well
looks great i will be back chatting to
you again in a minute if that's okay but
i just want to bring in um uh nz uh
intermittent rasheed who is uh one of my
colleagues who's also uh in we're gonna
to talk in a bit more detail about the
fact that almost a third of children in
wigan um are said to be um in poverty
thankfully you kids your mum manages to
put food in your belly every day which
is great and lindsey is standing by for
us this morning nc where are you tell us
more
morning kay just down the road from
where you are we're at fur clem
community hub an incredible place that
we've walked into
this morning
mainly a shop which provides
food for many people struggling
particularly
now through the cost of living crisis
for clem what does that mean in wiganese
it means that very hungry and that's the
name that the community hub has picked
here to serve people right across this
town who is struggling and has struggled
for a while but particularly now because
of the cost of living crisis i want to
bring in uh katie who's the director
here katie um what an incredible place
you've got just tell us a bit about the
community hub and the shop you've got
here at folkland um one of the things i
just want to say is not only does it
mean very hungry also means overcome
with emotion which is how we feel when
we're having to deal with people in the
community who are struggling and it's
how we feel when we see so much food
going to waste every day um so what
happens here is we save edible
waste from going to landfill we bring it
in and we make it available to the
community we put it at a fraction of the
cost that it will be in the supermarket
and it just gives people a chance to get
something for next to nothing
in terms of um what you offer here for
people um you know how does this system
work how do people come in here and kind
of make things happen so what happens is
they sign up and it's a membership it's
a membership scheme
they come in they can get five portions
of fruit and veg for one pound they can
have any portions that they like and
then everything else works on the
sticker system um so they build their
shopping around their sticker system
and we've reduced it so they can spend a
minimum of one pound but they can spend
as much as they want in our shop and
katie how important is it right now for
the community particularly here in wigan
to access something like this through
the times that people are going through
people are really struggling and i think
that food just helps with that issue so
if they can get some the food cheaper
than what they would do in the general
supermarket then they can save that
money to pay for other things like the
rising and fuel costs which is important
at the moment people still need to be
able to wash the clothes cook the food
and they need to
be able to heat the homes when it's cold
what are you finding it you know you've
been here for eight years but you've
adapted a lot over the last eight years
and what you're finding right now are
you seeing people struggling now more
than ever yeah i'm seeing more people
coming through the doors on a daily
basis i'm seeing people really
struggling and having to swallow the
pride to come here
and i'm seeing people spending less and
i think when you see people just
scraping together a pound to buy the
fruit vegetables you know there's an
issue katie thank you you're doing an
amazing job in the shop we're going to
see more facilities
that fur klemp have here including kind
of a cafe around the corner a kitchen
where they're going to be training
people to cook and how they can use
their kitchen facilities efficiently
but obviously an area which is really
assisting people at a time where they
need it the most and a community project
which is really on the front line when
it comes to tackling the cost of living
crisis here in wigan k
okay enzi for now thanks so much indeed
i found them here's ryan and he is uh
joe 28 year old working as working uh on
a local video production business called
foxy media house hi guys hello see you
i'm glad i found you tell me about
business yes so we're we set up during
the first lockdown
uh oh film production company yeah very
tough and uh we was bought for we both
lost well couldn't be employed anymore
because of the uh how difficult the
times were with the uh with corvid and
when our box was against the wall for
our we've been talking about it for
years let's do it so we set up boxing
media house within 12 months of us
starting up we had a first national
campaign and our first tv commercial and
we've sort of just gone from strength to
strength really uh we're currently
working on
uh building a
film and tv studio in the middle of
wigan um it's going to be specialized in
sort of green screen production we've
got a big infinity wall and editing
suite and uh yeah everything's looking
really promising so how difficult has it
been joe you know setting me up during
this period
difficult i think because well stirring
up a business i think
you have to be prepared to go 12 to 24
months without getting a single penny
yeah so i had savings like everyone does
well some people do
and i had to kind of just blow it all
and try and get this going but it is
what it is at home with your parents hi
i'm still home at the minute um
i'm i'm currently living in a
one-bedroom bedsit every every penny
i've just gone straight into this
business um we've had to completely go
back on absolutely everything um from
living off literally like sometimes
three to two pound a day on food like
that's just on food and stuff um
that to do honestly we're kind of people
who like to adapt to situations so if if
anything negative and anything in any
negative situation we'll all translate
the positive from it so
i'm gonna have to cut back and do all
that kind of stuff um were you entitled
to any grants
we already didn't really talk well i
mean i was i was i had a bedroom at the
time because what i was doing before
lockdown
and i was working as bear work on the
weekend
yeah um which was not obviously a great
deal and stuff then um
yeah every every hour every minute we're
just putting into boxing i mean we're
pretty good at adapting me and joe so
when lockdown came and we went to sort
of doing uh like live lab conferences
and stuff and like started shooting like
home workouts and uh
was making obviously a bit of money a
bit of money from that and then um
it gives us a lot of time to actually
create a solid business plan
and um
create like a website do all our
branding and stuff and then we always
sort of camera is it's been nowhere near
as easy as what i'm explaining it's
really incredible
incredibly incredibly challenging
i mean have you noticed the cost of
living so we had to move so at first we
had an office in leyland which is like
it's like 40 45 mile trip every single
day yeah yeah so a few was like a few
hundred pounds so that was the first
thing we had to knock on the head we
kind of been like right we have to
relocate it we can't afford this fuel
sure let's uh let's try and get someone
local so now we're situated at wigan
hall yeah
i mean our old studio was literally no
bigger than this sort of half a sizes
kitchen i had no windows it was at the
back of a warehouse and then um we sort
of got a more local space which was
smaller and then when lockdown finished
and everything was open again everyone
wanted content commercials doing and
stuff so
we was only in the new new unit and no
longer than 12 months and now we're in
um wigan hall which is quite a historic
building in the central town what's the
dream
we want to make commercials yeah massive
brands yeah right now we're currently
working with brands like under armour
nike um would you anthony joshua she has
pretty big brands too
yeah you just threw in the aj thing at
the end didn't you i was hoping you were
going to bring it up earlier
yeah so honestly yeah of course yeah so
i've been doing stuff with aj for like
six seven years now
and before it was huge um
i was creating content as like a
videographer yeah and i managed to
message him on instagram and some
somehow he phoned out my number and he
rang me amazing i was just saying they
saw seven number come through my phone i
was like hello he's like yes aj i wanted
i was like i was eight in spain working
as a videographer
for a golf company at the time it was uh
we started off creating like that social
post like instagram posts like really
low budget content and we started off
actually creating like content in the
clubs and pubs and wigan and that and um
this yeah we just thought of being
consistent with it being like i said
when when our backs are against the wall
and times are hard and times are tough
that's when we it's when we work at our
best you know i mean we don't give up
we're resilient and um yeah i think
i'm really looking forward to this new
studio which is being built right now
it's in the centre of amazing and it's
going to give the younger generation
yeah
chance to be inspired want to be working
with colleges school students you can
talk about the latest offer donkey kong
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i said it if you start
like that did you no no no
it's good to talk to both of you guys
throughout the week talking about the
cost of living crisis talking about
businesses like that i trying to recover
after the two years of the of the
pandemic they didn't get any money at
all during that period of time what is
it looking like between now and the end
of the year we're told that interest
rates could go up by something like 10
um 10 inflation i should say could go up
by something like 10 where is that going
to leave us so
leave us all we're gonna be talking
about that as i said throughout the
course of the week right now though we
want to find out about other headlines
don't we and i can tell you that boris
johnson is traveling to uh belfast today
threatening to rip up parts of the
northern ireland protocol and risk a
trade war with the eu uh our senior
island correspondent david blevins has
more for us david good morning to you
good morning kay from belfast a city of
course that would have much in common
with wigan in terms of the cost of
living crisis and a city that
desperately needs a new government
that's really why the prime minister is
coming to try and see the deadlock at
stormont broken he has written a lengthy
opinion piece in this morning's belfast
telegraph there are three daily
newspapers here one unionist one
nationalist the belfast telegraph falls
somewhere in the middle and that's where
he's chosen to make an appeal really he
talks about three things
firstly the need for the parties to get
back into the government the only one
refusing to do that right now is the dup
so that's clearly aimed at them he is
repeating the warning that the
government's prepared to take unilateral
action over the brexit protocol in other
words to strip away elements of the
treaty it signed with the eu to try and
avoid a border on this island and
thirdly and i think this is the most
interesting part he talks about a
potential landing zone that's exactly
the same language being used by the
irish foreign minister simon kovany and
it suggests that the uk government and
the eu have not given up hope of some
kind of agreed solution to this problem
without perhaps the government having to
go as far as to effectively tear up the
brexit deal it did with the eu
okay david for now thanks very much
indeed moved outside again so the family
can get on with their business i also
want to bring you other news and tell
you that sweden's parliament will hold a
debate later on today over nato
membership is what i'm being told
yesterday its governing party confirmed
its support for joining the military
alliance along with finland
meanwhile on the ground in ukraine
russian troops have been forced out of
the second city of kharkiv our
international affairs editor dominic
waghorn is in khaki for us this morning
hi dominic good morning to you explain
more to us about what's happening there
yeah hi okay well it's big news this
morning because the the governor of this
region says that ukrainian troops have
now got right up to the border with
russia so they have pushed russian
troops right out of the area around har
ki that's very significant for this war
for 79 days the russians have been
trying to get into hakeev ukraine's
second biggest city and the ukrainians
have been holding them off in really
intense fighting when they couldn't get
in they decided to try and destroy the
northern suburbs instead using
indiscriminate shelling we drove through
districts yesterday where the buildings
are pot marked they have big holes in
them and they are scorched by repeated
artillery attacks by the russians which
are surely evidence of war crimes and
the people there had to flee but instead
of getting out of the area they went
underground or they'd been living in
underground stations we saw them camped
out so they had as they have been for
more than two and a half months on the
platforms and in in the trains just like
londoners did during world war ii during
the blitz this victory now uh the
victory of the battle of haki for the
ukrainians is significant for them of
course because it means they can get out
even though they say they are pretty
reluctant at the moment there's still a
bit of artillery being exchanged by both
sides but it's really significant for
the ukrainians militarily because it
means that they can consolidate here and
then push further eastwards the russians
have been plagued by logistical problems
throughout this war and if the
ukrainians can get between their forces
fighting the donbass and their border
then they will sever their supply lines
running north to south and that means
that the russian forces that are already
floundering in donbass trying to take
donetsk and luhansk entirely means that
they will face an even bigger battle
supplying their uh forces with weapons
ammunition and with food and other
supplies so it's very significant on the
ground militarily and further setbacks
as you say
geopolitically for vladimir putin with
sweden finland giving up their
neutrality and saying they are going to
join nato within days
okay dominic for now thank you we'll
also making news for you on the
programme the breakfast programme for
you this morning live from wigan and let
me tell you about the us president joe
biden he's condemned the racially
motivated fatal shootings of 10 people
in the city of buffalo
as an abhorrent act the teen accused is
on suicide watch 11 of the 13 people who
were shot were black the 18 year old
suspect who is white has pleaded not
guilty president biden will travel to
buffalo tomorrow
we must all work together to address the
hate
that remains a stain
on the soul of america
our hearts are heavy once again
but a resolve
must never ever waver
let me also tell you about the queen we
saw her yesterday didn't we how fabulous
did she look she is attending the final
night of an ex
equestrian extravaganza i'm going to
have a run at that very slowly to
celebrate her platinum jubilee
just let that vehicle go best majesty
was met with a standing ovation as she
arrived at the royal windsor horse show
catherine jenkins and dame helen mirren
were among those performing at what was
the first major event marking the
queen's
70-year reign
okay let me uh talk to you in a little
bit more detail now about off gem some
breaking news that has been happening
and joining us is jonathan brielle he's
the ceo of offgem hello to you mr breely
so you're changing the rules explain
that to us
well let me start by saying i know how
many families are struggling with the
huge change in energy prices that we've
seen now off-gem is working very hard to
make sure that no one pays any more than
they need to for their energy costs what
we're announcing today is the price cap
that regulation that makes sure you
don't pay more than you need to for your
energy is updated more frequently so
we're going to change the price cap
every three months from october instead
of every six months as we used to and
the reason we're doing that is to make
sure that people pay a fair price for
their energy but also that companies can
manage in what is an incredibly volatile
market so yes it will go up as prices go
up but it will come down equally quickly
as prices come back down
but you acknowledge mr really do that if
this had been in place previously then
our bills would have gone up before this
april rise that we've seen now
well remember that the total cost you
pay over the year would be absolutely
the same because that reflects that only
the cost of the energy that we buy but
as i say yes the price would go up more
quickly as prices go up but equally
importantly as those prices come down
then the price cap comes back down again
i remember back in the 2010s when people
saw their prices go up and were waiting
and wondering why prices didn't come
down equally quickly the good thing
about the price cap is we will make sure
it only reflects cost and therefore it
only reflects what you need to pay for
your energy
but it is a bit swings and rounds advice
isn't it because as we made the point
there which you've conceded that the
price that we've seen this big jump that
we've seen in april we would have seen
that earlier than that if we had had
these checks every three months
well you would have seen that earlier
but that would have been moderated so it
wouldn't necessarily have been as large
a jump as we saw in april but the main
point is under any circumstances the
price cap will always be there to make
sure no one pays any more than they need
to for their energy the important thing
here is to make sure we have a market
that adapts to what is a very very
different global situation particularly
with the russian invasion of ukraine so
our job is to make sure the market is
resilient the market can manage but most
importantly customers pay no more than
they need to for their energy so this
announcement is really part of a much
bigger program to make sure we can
manage through what is an incredibly
tough time for customers and a turbulent
time for the industry now our job as i
say is to make sure we look after
customers interests and make sure people
pay no more than they need to
yeah do you acknowledge that uh it's
going to get tougher before it gets
better
well unfortunately and i've said this
publicly on a number of occasions now
with the russian invasion of ukraine we
are seeing a sustained increase and
further increase in gas prices so the
difficult news i have it is likely in
october that prices will go up again but
what we will do is we will make sure you
pay no more than the cost that you need
to for your energy and we're not going
back to bad old days where unfair
profits were charged by the retailers on
top of that
so is that a yes things are going to get
worse before they get better
so yes things are going to get tougher
as far as we can see it's not certain
the market is changing dramatically
almost day by day but we you know we
have to warn customers to expect further
price rises in october
um
we're at mickey's house today i don't
know if you've managed to watch any of
the program mr busley i'm sure you're
very busy um she has a pre-payment meter
when that runs out she has to light
candles to try to light the house what
would your advice be to her and other
people who are living here in wigan
look i know this is an incredibly tough
time for customers and i talk to
customers almost every week to make sure
i do understand what people are going
through our advice is simple please do
proactively get in touch with your
energy company there is help advice and
support that's available there are
amazing organizations who can support
you through this difficult time help you
understand how to manage your energy
bills and really help you through what
is an unprecedented set of circumstances
so get in touch with your company get
access to all the support that's
available and make sure you get the
advice that you need we also say to
families look if you are facing trouble
with your energy bills you may want
wider financial advice to make sure you
can manage all of the different issues
around the cost of living so far but to
emphasize we know this is difficult for
families we know this is difficult for
customers we're doing everything we can
to make sure that you pay a fair price
for your energy
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed for joining us on the
programme this morning we are in uh
wigan uh this morning um and uh a little
bit earlier on today mickey who is
hosting us in our home there she is hey
mickey chatting to some of our previous
guests as well we gave her the
opportunity to chat to the minister this
morning and this is what she asked him
my question to you minister is
my energy bills have risen by 80 pounds
a month and
where used to be 120 pounds is now
200 pounds if not more um if you include
the petrol and things so i'm just
wanting to ask
what are you going to be doing to help
people like me families like me
minister
yeah hello it's lovely to speak to you
and we we understand and we know the
impact that rising energy bills and
bills and costs of food are having on
families like yours all over the country
so
we very much do need to make sure that
the support is going to those families
the support packages that we've already
put in place
and we've already taken action to help
people with energy bills and there's
more help coming
couldn't come up to wigan without my
trusty winged woman could i good morning
good morning what did you make of things
this morning well very interesting from
the minister you know being directly
grilled on what do you do if the energy
bill has gone up by 80 pounds a month
the government talk about all the
support they're giving people for
example a rebate on the council tax of
150 pounds mickey and her family should
be getting that that's only two months
yeah what do they do for the rest of the
year as we just heard from the boss of
off germ it's not going to be good news
on energy bills for the rest of the year
however often they give us those energy
bills there's not going to be good news
when you read them so she talked about
for example the government's household
support fund we see ministers talk about
this rather a lot but as mickey put to
her people have a lot of difficulties
applying for it and in fact there was a
story at the weekend saying that some
local authorities ran out of money on
that one several months ago so for a lot
of people the support they have been
offered is really insufficient to meet
their needs and she talked about the
government is going to help you more
tantalizing what is that going to be we
expect that's not going to happen for
another couple of months at least but
they keep saying there's more support on
the way i think the groundswell of mps
now knowing that that has got to come
okay just before i let you go um i don't
understand how the prime minister's
blaming northern ireland on the protocol
on the coast of living what's up so
boris johnson is in belfast today
against all the parties he's written a
quite wide-ranging article actually
about the situation in northern ireland
as he sees it but introducing a new
dimension to why the brexit protocol he
signed back in 2019 i thought was great
at the time of and ready fantastic is
not working out and he said that it was
designed in a time before the covered
pandemic and before the russian invasion
of ukraine which has caused this cost of
living crisis and now of course it is
not acceptable he says have difficulties
getting medicines between gb and
northern ireland or difficulties in
cutting vat on certain products it's
only a part of his article but certainly
i think some will be saying look any
excuse but he's saying it's really
really his his broader point is it's
really really urgent that the unionist
and um shin fame get back into the
executive so they can tackle some of
these issues okay we've been very lucky
that mickey's hosting us today i know
we're still here
they were chatty chatty chatting
chatting as soon as i get on camera not
interested at all but what we do want to
do now and i'm privileged to be able to
talk to paul and carol barber and paul
and carol used to live or do live in the
first house that i bought when i lived
um in wigan once i got married hi paul
and carol
hey
hi good morning thank you so much for
taking the time to join us we really
appreciate it tell me about the house
what's it like now
same as it was when you lived here
[Laughter]
tell me tell me about the area where you
live because obviously i know but a lot
of people uh watching this morning don't
know
well it's quite a rural area where we
are we're not actually in the center of
wood and we're outside so um you know
quite green really a lot where we are in
in this estate quite a quiet estate
really yeah we're about three miles from
cities from wigan town centre
yeah i mean it's it's a lovely house i
can't it's got three bedrooms i think as
i remember um how difficult is it to
sort of you know
keep keep things together i i it's a
little bit it is quite an affluent area
of wigan i have to say it's aptly bridge
it's slightly outside as you said um how
are you finding um the cost of living
increase
well you go to the supermarket every
week and every time you go things have
gone up you know i think i think boris
is out of touch with the average
working-class man to be honest
yeah so what what are you suggesting
what are you saying to the government
this morning
well i think you should start taxing
these uh big fuel companies that are
making millions and millions up to the
north sea
and uh they don't pay any tax
yeah
um i think am i right in saying paul
that you you're a driver so you're up
and down the motorway quite a few times
a week i'm guessing you've seen big
increases in fuel costs as well have you
oh yeah yeah every day
it's about an extra hundred pounds a day
to fuel the wagon
wow is it really my goodness me i'm just
looking at the house i'm trying to
figure out
i'm trying to figure out where you sat
and where you are in the house i don't
suppose you can just give me a quick
pan round with the camera did you
well this is yeah we're actually in the
dining room
oh
nice
this is so we've like just we opened it
all up so it's all just one way i'm not
very good at it
okay
it's good to see you guys thank you so
much for taking the time to join us i
know you've got to rush off to go to
work so i'm going to leave you to it
thank you very much thank
you all right no problem thank you dad
enjoy the house enjoy the house thank
you thank you cheers
there we go lovely thank you
oh i remember that oh they've got rid of
the louvre doors that i used to have
there uh
joining us now in just a moment or two
we're going to be uh chatting to a
fantastic young man who um has a social
care to help him uh day to day how is he
coping with the cost of living with fine
out after we've heard from katarina
yeah get up it might be like five
o'clock
i'll have a snooze button i think
it's gonna be a long day
andy nichols works almost every hour he
can he has
three jobs which combined bring him in
38 000 pounds well above the uk average
but now not enough to cover his costs
and
save when you know you've done 63 64 65
hours but then a shift comes up of let's
say a six hour shift and you think
physically can i and i think but it's
that extra little bit of money
andy who is 42 has now moved back in
with his parents
it's the only way he can save enough to
afford his own home
when i do get in um the place of my own
when i do get in that i'm thinking
am i then going to have enough money to
to pay my gas pay me electric and pay
pay the water bill and just say
everything's going up
many people many families in wigan are
now only just coping
free food parcels are going out every
day from this youth center to a growing
number of wigan families where there's
pressure on children to contribute
financially
the question of uni is out the window
are you raised that topic or i just want
i just need to go work
but really these are some of them can go
to uni and they can excel in those
careers in future that will then help
them get better jobs but it's they need
to work for the now
gemma is 17.
she lost her part-time job during the
covered pandemic and is trying
desperately to help out with the family
bills
at the minute we are struggling a bit
like we're putting back on quite a lot
of stuff
like what sort of thing
like we used to do like a food shop
every two weeks like little ones so now
we have to budget it so then we do like
one big one at the end of the month
it's quite scary to be honest because
you never know if you do have a job if
you're going to get let go
and obviously with the prices of
everything rising
it's just really hard at the minute
because you want to do stuff you love
but obviously you need the essentials as
well
gemma says for now her own ambitions are
on hold
futures are hard to plan
when the present feels so uncertain
catherine of autopsy sky news in wigan
um just want to give you a quick insight
into the cost of living being
particularly tough for those receiving
disability uh benefits and joining us uh
now is alex
and also hayden now we're going to chat
to you in much more detail in the next
hour but just hi good morning how are
you doing
i love that smile i love that smile tell
me what you do
yeah so
happy smiles training we empower
disabled people to create positive
change by using their lived experience
to deliver training to schools and
community groups and businesses hayden
and i set up in 2019. yeah in 2019 just
before the pandemic just before six
months not the best time to leave your
job and set up personalization so i want
to talk to you in more detail about what
you do and i know that you're going to
talk to us via your ipad and we've got
some questions that we've got for you a
little bit later on but what's it like
living in wigan and the sort of
challenges that you're facing in just
about 30 seconds or so
yeah morning everybody
that's because that's for you that here
yeah exactly
of course they do yeah no i'm really
passionate wigginer myself and i'm
heading out we we love living in wigan
but yeah lots of challenges that you're
going to talk about hayden yeah
particularly disabled people are facing
locally and nationally um because of the
rising costs so yeah looking forward to
speaking about it okay well looking
forward to it and you're going to chat
to us in the next hour aren't you so
we'll see you again then guys if that's
where it's flipping freezing outside
let's see if we can get you inside thank
yeah that's true that's true we're going
to have much much more from local
residents here in wigan who are feeling
the pinch because of the cost of living
increase we've been challenging the
minister this morning of course and
we'll be finding out what she had to say
to mickey in the next hour here on sky
do stay tuned our way
[Music]